cosa dove cazzo è impossibile Non ci
crederò mai siete riusciti a
consigliarmi il videogioco che mi ha
scassato le cuffie una cosa Pronto Sì sì
pizzeria Apri pizzeria questa cosa ti
porto
quattro formaggi Sì prosciutto No
prosciutto perfetto eh Però mi dispiace
mi stai dando fastidio quindi ti muto
Buongiorno voglio questo tutta la vita
bellissima Ti chiamerò Alan perché
sicuramente un figo Comunque chi è che
ride Non ho capito Che cazzo è che ride
da mezz'ora Alan cosa cazzo stai facendo
lì ti sei dato a Rock and roll fa mica
c'è Alan Guarda io lo capisco che stare
in compagnia di sti [__] non è
proprio il massimo della vita però mio
Dio cioè che stare in compagnia di
studenti
[Musica]